alors
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat dans un instant vous
allez pouvoir suivre un débat sur
l'application des lois pour en parler à
mes côtés yvon collin le président du
groupe rdse le groupe du rassemblement
social démocratique erokhin qui est à
l'initiative de ce débat alors le
traditionnel rapport du sénat sur
l'application des lois est sorti on
observe un ralentissement des progrès
observés l'an dernier sur justement la
mise en application par le gouvernement
des lois comment explique-t-on ce recul
je crois quand le parlement légifère
le parlement fait des lois souvent on
fait des lois dans l'urgence on nous
demande beaucoup travaillé de jour de
nuit mais on a souvent la surprise de
constater là ce que les lois ne trouvent
pas de suites et les décrets
d'application tarde à venir
à quoi sert-il de faire des lois si
effectivement les décrets d'application
n'entre pas en vigueur
et donc c'est ce toilettage qui est
absolument nécessaire
on constate donc que il ya un effet
récurrentes réguliers et ça ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui sur tout sur toutes les
républiques si je puis dire
nous avons constaté qu'effectivement le
gouvernement les gouvernements
successifs tarder à mettre en
application des lois et il ya donc là
quelque part un dévoiement de la volonté
du peuple traduit à travers ces
parlementaires de faire en sorte que les
lois qui sont l'aboutissement
effectivement d'un besoin d'une volonté
est bien ne sont pas ne sont pas
appliquées il ya donc un vrai préjudice
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs le groupe rdse défendra le 17
février un texte qui permettra à tout
parlementaire de saisir la justice dès
lors qu'il y a en défaut d'application
de la loi ça me paraît un vide juridique
qu'il faut combler et cette ppl cette
proposition de loi
que jus dont je suis le premier
signataire été portée par le rdse a pour
ambition effectivement de mettre un peu
d'ordre et de faire en sorte que l'on
puisse lorsqu'il ya ce préjudice parce
que la loi n'est pas appliquée que le
gouvernement puisse être mise en demeure
par les tribunaux et donc c'est la
faculté pour les parlementaires de se
saisir et de saisir des tribunaux pour
faire appliquer la loi tout simplement
vous attendez de ce débat aujourd'hui
c'est patrick ollier le ministre en
charge des relations gouvernement qui
vient ici au sénat vous attendait une
réponse vous attendez des engagements
sur la parution de certains décrets
d'application de certaines lois verrez
le texte que je vais prononcer là
l'intervention de cet après midi
quelques minutes pour dire effectivement
pour faire un bilan qui est assez lourd
puisque pratiquement en quarts des
textes des lois ne trouve pas une pleine
application de leurs effets des effets
que attendait les parlementaires
lorsqu'ils les ont votés et donc c'est
un bilan
triste bilan si je puis dire et c'est
pour le rappeler à patrick ollier qui si
je puis dire n'y est pour rien il se
saisit aujourd'hui il aura la charge de
répondants le gouvernement mais ce qui
est ce que l'on constate c'est que cette
récurrence et inadmissible est ce que
nous souhaiterions ce que je vais dire à
patrick ollier c'est que lorsque le
gouvernement propose un texte
eh bien il faudrait pratiquement que les
décrets d'application soient déjà
préparé de manière à ce que dès que le
sud le texte est adopté
eh bien il trouve sa pleine application
ainsi nos concitoyennes effectivement
verront une vraie adéquation entre la
volonté du texte qui est proposé du
texte qu'ils ont voté et son application
sur le terrain qu'attendent les effets
qu'il est censé produire
autre sujet d'actualité la semaine
dernière christian jacob donc le nouveau
patron des députés ump à l'assemblée
nationale se prononcer pour la publicité
des débats en commission c'est également
votre souhait vous pouvez nous expliquer
pourquoi
oui ma position est connue et j'ai mené
je mène ce combat depuis la révision
constitutionnelle
on s'aperçoit que c'est désormais
le les commissions qui font une oeuvre
législative puisque c'est désormais sur
le texte de édictées par la commission
construit par la commission que en
séance plénière le sénat se prononce et
l'assemblée nationale aussi d'ailleurs
et donc dès lors que les commissions
forme oeuvre législative
eh bien je crois qu'il faut que ça se
fasse en pleine transparence et je fais
partie des parlementaires rare encore
mais je vois que alors christian jacob
s'est emparé de ce sujet je suis ravi de
ne plus être seul pour s'apercevoir
effectivement qu'il faut que une
publicité plus large une vraie
transparence soit donnée au travail des
commissions d'ailleurs sans
revaloriserait me semble-t-il le travail
dès le travail des parlementaires
c'est absolument nécessaire bien entendu
certains présidents de commissions et
c'est légitime demande que parfois on
puisse faire des huit clos ça je trouve
tout à fait normal il peut y avoir
certains sujets qui donnent qui donne
qui permette requis en tout cas
nécessitent des discussions à huis clos
bien entendu chaque fois que les prises
en commission le seul le cela
ressemblera nécessaire bien entendu
qu'ils pourront cotiser mais je crois
qu'il faut vraiment ouvrir portes et
fenêtres nous n'avons rien à cacher nous
travaillons beaucoup et ce serait
d'ailleurs une façon de montrer combien
le parlement travaille pas ce commando
trop souvent l'hémicycle vide et je
crois que les nos concitoyens
s'apercevront qu'en commission est un
travail très intéressant où nous
construisons chacun en apparaît qu'un
apport nous discutions des textes une
dernière question votre collègue jean
michel baylet a récemment estimé que
seul un radical soit en mesure de
conquérir la présidence du sénat à
l'automne à l'occasion des prochaines
sénatoriales est ce que vous partagez
son analyse écoutez
c'est une c'est une belle audace
effectivement gaston monnerville de
dernier président radical en tant que
radical bien sûr que je souhaiterais
comme donc un radical préside le sénat
mais je crois qu'il faut savoir
l'équilibré des forces en septembre la
constitution des groupes voir dans quel
sens se sont infléchies le rapport de
force
et puis à ce moment là effectivement
bien il arrive nous appartiendra
d'élaborer des stratégies
peut-être est-ce prématurée merci yvon
collin d'avoir répondu à nos questions à
suivre donc cet après midi sur public
sénat un débat sur l'application des
lois très bonne science est tous l'ordre
du jour appelle le débat sur les diction
des mesures réglementaires d'application
des lois
la parole est tout d'abord à l'orateur
du groupe qui a demandé ce débat
monsieur yvon collin président du groupe
du rassemblement démocratique et social
européen hauteur de la demande monsieur
le président donc j'attends
mais oui
madame le président sur le ministre
chers collègues
si le groupe du rdr souhaité que le
sénat débattent aujourd'hui de
l'éviction des mesures réglementaires
d'application des lois c'est qui nous
est apparu qu'il existait un vrai
décalage entre d'une part l'objectif de
rééquilibrage des institutions en faveur
du parlement et d'autre part la mise en
application par le gouvernement de la
volonté exprimée par nos deux assemblées
au travers du vote de la loi
enfin l'impératif d'amélioration de la
qualité de la loi
soyons clairs le droit ne peut être
efficace et compris par nos concitoyens
que s'il est correctement produit et
mise en application
or tel n'est assurément pas le cas
l'actualité toute récente nous fournit
un exemple probant
le conseil d'état a transmis le 30
décembre dernier au conseil
constitutionnel une question prioritaire
de constitutionnalité portant sur
l'application de la loi du 5 mars 2007
réformant la protection de l'enfance
la haute juridiction administrative a
estimé dans son arrêt de transmission
que si l'article 27 de cette loi crée un
fonds national de financement destiné à
compenser les charges nouvelles des
départements selon les critères fixés
par décret c'est bien parce que ce
décret n'a jamais été pris par le
gouvernement et qu'il existe un doute
sérieux quant à la constitutionnalité de
cet article
tout est dit la carence du pouvoir
réglementaire qu'elle soit politique ou
non qui alimente l'insécurité juridique
et finit par porter atteinte à la
protection de l'intérêt général
mes chers collègues l'office des
législateurs que nous incarnons est
d'abord et avant tout de voter la loi
c'est-à-dire une norme générale et
impersonnelle fixant sur les termes de
l'article 34 de la constitution des
règles et des principes
toujours selon la logique nos
institutions il revient ensuite
au pouvoir réglementaire de fixer les
modalités d'application des lois par les
diction de normes réglementaires
ce pouvoir réglementaire est une
compétence du premier ministre à
laquelle il associe et contre st les
ministres chargés de l'exécution de ses
actes il ressort de cette architecture
institutionnelle que la volonté du
législateur qui exprime la volonté
générale de la nation et dépendantes
vous l'aurez compris de la bonne
exécution des lois par le pouvoir
réglementaire qui en est
constitutionnellement chercher or ce bel
ordonnancement n'est que théorique
notre haute assemblée met en oeuvre
depuis maintenant près de 40 ha en
contrôle de la mise en application des
lois le dernier rapport paru sur ce
sujet en décembre dernier montre à quel
point
l'exécution des lois souffre de retards
voire de carence qui altèrent parfois
gravement l'application concrète de la
volonté du parlement et les chiffres ne
font pas honneur à la célérité qui
devait pourtant mobilisés monsieur le
ministre le gouvernement et je sais que
vous en être convaincu ainsi sur les
1600 cinq lois promulguées depuis 1981
243 soit près de 15% sont toujours en
attente d'une mesure réglementaire
la plus ancienne gloire monte à 84 pire
26 de ses textes dont le plus ancien
date de mines de 1997 n'ont encore reçu
aucune des mesures réglementaires
requises pour ne pas faire mentir cette
tendance il apparaissait au 31 décembre
2009 que seul 71% des mesures
réglementaires prévues depuis le début
de la législature avaient été publiées
pour ce qui concerne la session 2009
2010 close le 30 septembre dernier le
parlement avait définitivement votée 59
lois dont 35 prévoyant un suivi
réglementaire soit près de 670 mesures
d'application nécessaire
seuls trois de ses 37 loi avait reçu
l'intégralité de leurs mesures
réglementaires d'application
19 été partiellement applicable et très
été totalement inapplicable soit
pratiquement vous levez vous le
constatez une loi sur 4 ha je concède
parmi que parmi ces lois figurent des
textes qui avaient été votées pendant la
session extraordinaire monsieur le
ministre je vous en donne le mais il
n'en demeure pas moins que ce taux
d'inexécution n'est pas acceptable et
illustre à l'évidence le décalage
frappant entre le rythme de travail
imposé au parlement et on connaît ce
rythme et c'est pas près de s'arrêter si
j'ai bien compris ce chiffre est clair
d'ailleurs particulièrement ce propos
seul 12,5 pour cent des mesures
d'application des lois votées selon la
procédure accélérée ont été publiées
contre 21% en 2008 2009
en d'autres termes monsieur le ministre
plus votre gouvernement demande la
procédure accélérée - il arrive à suivre
le rythme qu'il impose ce qui vous le
concéder n'est guère à son honneur
ces statistiques que nous devons au
remarquable travail de recension de nos
commissions permanentes démontre que la
façon dont notre république produit ces
normes n'est pas bonne et qu'elle doit
être changé mes chers collègues
la première cause de ces malfaçons
juridique nous la connaissons tous
l'inflation normative entre lesdits de
villers cotterêts en caisse 239 et
l'avènement de la vème république
le nombre de normes promulguée est
beaucoup moins important que le nombre
de normes promulguées depuis seulement
1958 le recueil des lois publiées par
l'assemblée nationale est passée de 620
pages 1912 g en 1970 à 2556 page et 3266
g brice et précis en 2004 fin aux 9000
loire et 120 milles décret recensés en
2000 s'ajoutent chaque année presque une
centaine de lois plus de 50 ordonnance
et 1500 décret même l'oeuvre de
simplification du droit est devenu
source de complexité
la récente proposition de loi de
simplification et d'amélioration de la
qualité du droit que nous avons disque
t na n'est d'ailleurs que le dernier
avatar à cette inflation législative
répond naturellement une inflation des
mesures d'application 670 mesure en 2009
2010 6 115 en 2008 2009 3 195 à
2007-2008 et 548 en 2006 2007
corrélativement le nombre moyen le
nombre moyen des mesures d'application
demandé par la loi atteignez pour la
dernière session 10 9 contre 11 en 2007
2008 et 24 en 2008-2009 il s'agit là des
chiffres moyens
dans le même registre la qualité
rédactionnelle des lois a elle aussi
considérablement pâti de cet état de
fait la logorrhée législatives engendre
souvent des lois mal rédigé sujet à
plusieurs interprétations qui affecte
d'autant plus l'édiction de leurs
mesures d'application les mesures de
nature réglementaire incluse dans la loi
pullulent et tendent à faire abolir
de fait la frontière entre le domaine de
la loi et le domaine du règlement
c'est récurrent nous revenons toujours
sur ce problème
ce que pierre mazeaud d'ailleurs appelé
les neutrons législatif - légiférer pour
rendre notre droit plus lisible et mieux
applicables
tel devrait pourtant être le credo de
notre légistique les retards de
publication des décrets d'application ne
sont pas nouveaux je le constate
monsieur le ministre
ils ont même été à l'origine il y a une
trentaine d'années de proposition de
révision de la constitution selon
laquelle selon lesquelles après
l'expiration d'un délai déterminé la
commission permanente parlementaires
compétentes se serait substitué au
gouvernement pour prendre des mesures
nécessaires
pourtant la doctrine juridique à l'image
de léon duguit a longtemps considéré que
même si la loi un parti c'est un délai
pour les diction des décrets
d'application
elle ne faisait naître aucune obligation
à la charge du gouvernement
garder sa liberté d'appréciation mais ne
pouvait être vue comme fautif
juridiquement monsieur le ministre si
votre gouvernement n'a pas inventé la
surproduction de loi ou les retards à
prendre les décrets le concède il est en
revanche un de ceux qui a le plus
contribué à dévoyer la loi de son
essence première de normes générales et
abstraites la révision constitutionnelle
de 2008 qui devait c'était un des
objectifs principaux
revaloriser le rôle du parlement à lui
assurant une meilleure maîtrise des
travaux législatifs n'a pas eu loin s'en
faut
les effets escomptés l'action politique
a pris la forme d'une gesticulation
législatives la loi doit être solennel
brève et permanente
aujourd'hui elle est bavarde précaires
et banalisé déclaré déjà en 2005
renaud denoix de saint marc à leur vice
président du conseil d'état
cette gesticulation législatives c'est
celle que votre majorité promeut à
chaque fois comme un fait divers
dramatique frapper l'opinion et que vous
y répondez par un projet de loi trop
souvent bâclés et que vous les faire
adopter
bien entendu au plus vite l'émotion
monsieur le ministre ne saurait
remplacer la raison lorsqu'il est
question de légiférer dans l'intérêt
général
cette gesticulation c'est celle encore
que vous imposez au parlement par la
procédure accélérée qui annihile tout
débat tout analyser tout recul pouvant
pourtant inhérents à la fonction
législative
c'est enfin celle qui visse notre propre
action et votre crédibilité dès lors que
l'antre des textes n'a même pas le temps
de sécher qui sont déjà remplacé par
d'autres dont on ne sait pas d'ailleurs
s'ils sont d'avis ils seront davantage
mise en application
je ne peux accepter vous l'aurez compris
que la loi soit votée avait l'oeil
toujours fixé sur les courbes des
sondages où les manchettes des journaux
or c'est bien parce que de telles
conditions de travail sont imposés au
parlement que la qualité de la loi se
dégrade
et que les décrets d'application
prennent autant de retard les services
de l'administration sont aujourd'hui
encombrée par les projets de décrets en
raison de l'accumulation des textes
toujours plus complexe mais rédigé
parfois dans la hâte
ce n'est pas ainsi monsieur le ministre
que nous concevons l'intérêt génère des
chers collègues face à ce constat
désabusé il existe heureusement des
solutions
la première d'entre elles la plus
évidente de consisterait à mieux réguler
la production législative pour abaisser
le rythme nécessaire la publication des
décrets d'application
une telle mesure nécessiterait de
revenir aux préceptes formulée par
portalis qui nous regardent
la loi permet ordonne est interdit et
mais je ne suis pas sûr que le mouvement
actuel se tarissent rapidement a
fortiori monsieur le ministre lorsque
vous annoncer pas plus tard qu'hier dans
une interview accordée au quotidien bien
connu je bous sylt un ordre du jour
plein à craquer et ce jusqu en 2012 nous
le confirmera sans doute le risque
juridique et pourtant pas temps puisque
le conseil d'état annulé dès 1962 le
refus d'édicter des règlements
d'application et considère depuis 1964
que ce refus est fautif et engage la
responsabilité administrative il a même
jugé en 2000 je cite que l'exercice du
pouvoir réglementaire comporte non
seulement le droit mais aussi
l'obligation de prendre dans un délai
raisonnable les mesures qu implique
nécessairement l'application de la loi
or le cas où le respect des engagements
internationaux de la france y ferait
obstacle
la solution doit donc d'abord être
politique et volontaire la plus évidente
à nos yeux et nous ne sommes pas les
seuls à la formule et consisterait par
conséquent à ce que le gouvernement
s'astreignent à transmettre dès le dépôt
du projet de loi
les projets de dépôt 2
décret correspondant à l'image des
études d'impact désormais
obligatoirement alexis au projet de loi
et qui impose en principe une
argumentation plus serré et une
meilleure justification des dispositions
proposées
c'est d'ailleurs une telle initiative
qu'avait pris en 1990 michel rocard
alors premier ministre lorsqu'il impose
à à ses ministres de préparer avant même
la présentation en conseil des ministres
des projets de lois les décrets
d'application ainsi que les grandes
lignes du calendrier de leur publication
cette solution nous paraît tellement
évidente qu'elle existe des gens réalité
l'article 67 de la loi du 9 décembre
2004 de simplification du droit fait
ainsi déjà obligation au gouvernement de
publier des rapports sur la mise en
application de chaque loi
six mois après son entrée en vigueur
cannes est il aujourd'hui
monsieur le ministre de ces rapports je
vous rappellerai également que la
circulaire du premier ministre du 29
février 2008 impose une obligation de
résultat ministre quant à la mise en
application des lois
elle demande ainsi à chaque ministre de
créer au sein de son administration une
structure chargée de coordonner le
travail de mise en application des lois
d'améliorer le travail de coordination
interministérielle de fixer des
échéanciers transmis au parlement et de
prendre dans les six mois suivant la
publication d'une loi l'ensemble des
mesures d'application
or si le gouvernement a bien pris soin
de transmettre depuis 2008 les
échéanciers de publication des textes
réglementaires seuls 79 % des mesures
réglementaires prises en 2009 2010 ont
été publiés dans un délai de six mois
contre 82 % en 2008-2009
il pourrait donc être envisagé que le
gouvernement informe dans les meilleurs
délais les commissions compétentes du
parlement des motifs du retard de
publication
en toute hypothèse force est donc de
constater que votre gouvernement encore
beaucoup de travail à mener pour
parvenir à une meilleure organisation de
son travail et mieux informer le
parlement
il doit par conséquent également échoir
à nos assemblées parlementaires
de mieux déployer les moyens dont elle
dispose pour accomplir leur mission de
contrôle politique et informel de
l'action du gouvernement
rénové depuis 2008 s'est déjà d'ailleurs
ce que fait en partie l'assemblée
nationale où les députés qui rapportent
un projet de loi sont également chargé
d'assumer le contrôle de leur exécution
par la publication d'un rapport sans
doute de senna pourrait t'il s'inspirer
de cette pratique qui contribue à une
meilleure information de tous
tous les parlementaires est d'ailleurs
également du grand public
l'adoption de la proposition de loi du
président accoyer qui renforce les
moyens du parlement en matière de
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
nous aidera aussi certainement mais
au-delà de ce contre l'informel et
politique se pose la question du
contrôle juridique dans la mesure où
comme je viens de le dire la
responsabilité ministre de l'état peut
être engagée si le retard excessif
d'édiction d'une mesure réglementaire
peut être contestés par toute personne
ayant un intérêt
il est à notre sens regrettable que les
parlementaires ne puissent s qualité
introduire un tel recours or l'inaction
du pouvoir et le mans terrain qui peut
être tout à fait volontaire revient à
priver les faits des faits la volonté du
parlement souverain qui exprime je le
rappelle la volonté générale
la jurisprudence administrative ne
reconnaît pas l'intérêt à agir d'un
parlementaire sur le seul fondement de
sa qualité d'élu
quand bien même il contesterait
l'inaction fautive du premier ministre
ou encore le non respect de la volonté
du parlement
c'est pourquoi le groupe du rdse a
demandé l'inscription à son ordre du
jour réservé du 17 février prochain de
sa proposition de loi tendant à
reconnaître une présomption d'intérêt à
agir des membres de l'assemblée
nationale et du sénat
en matière de recours d'excès de pouvoir
au moment où s'engage donc ce débat sur
les diction des mesures réglementaires
d'application des lois
nous estimons tout à fait utile de
porter notre réflexion sur les moyens
qui pourraient être mises en oeuvre par
le parlement pour s'assurer que sa
volonté soit respectée par le pouvoir
réglementaire
à l'aube de cette année nouvelle soyez
en tout cas rassuré monsieur le ministre
j'en profite pour vous présenter two
lovers que les membres du rdse se
montreront très vigilants quant à
l'application de votre gouvernement des
lois votées par le parlement de la
république je vous remercie de votre
grande attention
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à monsieur patrice gélard pour le
groupe ump
mais c'est tout petit
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je n'ai pas
grand chose à ajouter à ce que viennent
dit à notre collègue colin et je serai
amené sans doute à me a répété ce qu'il
a dit sur un certain nombre de points
d'autant plus qu'un grand quotidien du
soir a repris presque in extenso les
conclusions du rapport de notre
assemblée sur justement les statistiques
et les chiffres concernant l'application
des lois et le développement des décrets
alors je ne ferai pas de reprise
statistique
je ne citerai pas les chiffres qui ont
si bien été cités tout à l'heure et qui
seront certainement re cité par les
autres intervenants
par conséquent je vais plutôt me limiter
à un certain nombre d'éléments de nature
générale pour essayer d'expliquer à la
fois le bilan
les raisons et les solutions que l'on
pourrait apporter à la situation
actuelle
alors bien évidemment nous sommes en
face d'un bilan peu satisfaisant qui est
permanent qui existait déjà autrefois à
l'époque des républiques précédentes les
choses ne se sont guère améliorées et
ils les ont tendance à ne pas
s'améliorer
alors pourquoi ne s'améliore t'elle pas
avait pour une raison relativement
simple et notre ami colin nous l'a dit
assez nettement tout à l'heure tout
d'abord le nombre de lois est excessif
en france nous ne sommes plus en mesure
d'adopter une soixantaine de loi par an
et d'en assurer le suivi
je crois que là il ya un élément tout à
fait important qu'il faut prendre à
l'esprit et il faut savoir aussi que
c'est ces lois sont généralement
insuffisamment préparés alors pourquoi
sont-elles a suffisamment préparés pour
plusieurs raisons la première raison est
là je citerai le président guy braibant
lorsqu'il était à la tête de la
commission des études et du rapport du
conseil d'état où il souligné que la
formation juridique des hauts
fonctionnaires laissait à désirer et
qu'il convenait de développer cette
formation juridique en précisant que
nous étions l'un des rares pays où la
formation juridique était en baisse
par rapport à ce qui se passait dans les
états voisins alors il ya donc là un
élément il est effectif que rédigé un
projet de décret rédigé un projet de loi
ça ne s'improvise pas et qu'il faut
naturellement un minimum de formation
préliminaire
donc il ya déjà sept éléments et puis il
faut pas oublier une chose c'est qu'elle
certain nombre de textes juridiques
adoptés par nos assemblées ne plaisent
pas au gouvernement et par conséquent le
gouvernement je dirais traînera un peu
les pieds avant d'adopter les règlements
j'ai un exemple tout à fait évident à
l'esprit j'avais été le rapporteur de la
dernière loi adoptée en 2002 par notre
assemblée sur la création de la
fondation des études comparatif monsieur
chances de bergues et ministre à
l'époque il était à la place de monsieur
ollier et il avait défendu ce texte que
j'avais rapporté que j'avais défendu
également et ce texte le lendemain ou le
surlendemain avait été adopté conforme
par l'assemblée nationale
alors ce texte est bien n'a jamais vu du
décret d'application et résultat quand
on voit la proposition warsmann dans
l'un de ses articles 30 et quelques on
annonce que cette loi adoptée en 2002
est abrogé elle n'a jamais eu le moindre
début de commencement d'application
elle n'a jamais vu le jour et il est
vrai que c'est toi nécessité de dégager
des crédits ces crédits nous sommes
étaient des gaz et par qui que ce soit
et par conséquent c'était une loi morny
ce n'est pas la seule je pourrais citer
un autre exemple ou là y avait pas de la
mauvaise volonté du gouvernement tong
tél mais les enjeux étaient si
importants qu'on ne pouvait pas
brutalement adopté les décrets c'est la
fameuse loi littoral la loi littoral
adoptée à l'unanimité par nos deux
assemblées faut se méfier comme de la
peste des lois adoptées à l'unanimité
généralement elle cache un certain
nombre d'anomalies ou de
dysfonctionnements ces lois adoptées à
l'unanimité mais il a fallu 18 ans
pour que les décrets d'application
soient tous adoptés pendant ce temps là
le conseil d'état ayant estimé ainsi que
les tribunaux administratifs que la loi
même sens les décrets étaient
d'application directe
nous avons eu cette spécificité bien
française qui consiste à appliquer une
loi incomplètes et en fin de compte à
transformer le juge administratif en
législateur au lieu et place du
parlement
alors voilà certain nombre d'éléments
tout à fait important est en fait aussi
un autre élément qui apparaît bien dans
le rapport établi par le sénat c'est le
problème des lois anciennes les lois
anciennes qu'on a complètement oublié
soit qu'elles remontent à une précédente
législature mais où les décrets
d'application n'ont toujours pas vu le
jour
ces lois anciennes on les abandonne
progressivement et donc s'il faudra les
loi de simplification administrative
faut qu'on les abroge une par une les
unes après les autres en ne se
préoccupant pas tellement des raisons
pour lesquelles on les avait adopté huit
neuf ou dix ans auparavant alors face à
cette situation
quels sont les moyens qui nous
permettrait de rester d'abord il ya une
conséquence directe de cette situation
et mes chocolats la très bien souligner
c'est que nous mélangeons allègrement
les dispositions réglementaires à
l'intérieur de nos lois alors que nous
devrions systématiquement et que le
gouvernement devrait systématiquement
opposer l'irrecevabilité à l'égard de
tous les amendements notamment qui
empiètent sur le domaine réglementaire
résultat on laisse passer les choses
d'abord parce que ça arrange tout le
monde
ça arrange le gouvernement qui du même
coup ne soit pas obligé par des traits
de faire en sorte qu'il complète la loi
et ça arrange parlement qui comme ça se
rassure en disant au moins dans le
décret y aura ce que j'ai mis dans la
loi donc il ya là des dispositions que
l'on respecte pas mais ça cet ancien il
ya déjà très longtemps depuis les débuts
de la vème république qu'on soulignait
que l'article 34 l'article 37
malheureusement n'était pas souvent
respectée
alors j'en viens aux solutions que nous
pourrions envisager
d'abord il ya un double volet il ya les
solutions qui pourraient être envisagées
par le gouvernement et il ya celles qui
le met nous parlement directement en
cause de la situation actuelle n'est pas
le seul fait du gouvernement il est
aussi le fait du parlement lui-même qui
ferment les yeux trop souvent qu'ils
acceptent souvent un certain nombre de
délits alors tout d'abord de la part du
gouvernement
je devrais je dois souligner que les
études d'impact sont insuffisantes
en règle générale elles sont rapidement
trop rapidement fait et les études
d'impact bien fait généralement indique
une loi bien fait et indique que les
propos des projets de décret sont déjà
prévus et analyser à l'intérieur des
études d'impact alors c'est parce que
l'étude d'impact généralement se résume
à deux ou trois pages et qu'il n'y a pas
véritablement ce qui devrait figurer
dans une étude d'impact ensuite deuxième
élément et c'est la raison pour laquelle
je pense ce que le devrions avoir un
renforcement du rôle et de la place du
secrétariat général du gouvernement dont
la mission justement est d'assurer une
bonne coordination du travail législatif
et réglementaire alors le secrétariat
général du gouvernement premier lieu
devrait pouvoir prévoir et préparer des
calendriers des calendrier d'adoption
des textes législatifs mais aussi les
calendriers l'adoption des textes
réglementaires qui serait mis en
communication facilement son rôle étant
d'assurer la coordination entre les
différents ministères et la coordination
des relations avec le parlement et
ensuite je pense qu'il faudrait étoffer
le secrétariat général du gouvernement
qui est une bonne équipe mais
insuffisante en nombre et qui devrait
disposer d'avoir plus de collaborateurs
pour pouvoir mener à bien des travaux
complexes et difficiles notamment dans
un domaine que l'on oublie souvent quel
domaine de l'outre-mer
ou par exemple dans l'outre-mer le
retard est considérable en ce qui
concerne l'adoption des décrets
d'application alors assuré un calendrier
faire en sorte que le secrétariat
général du gouvernement sont dotés d'un
peu plus de moyens
il ya aussi une autre solution cet autre
solution c'est que les lois soient plus
courtes elles sont beaucoup trop longue
une loi de 10 articles c'est au minimum
cet amendement et c'est au minimum un
renvoi à trois décrets d'application si
nous avons une loi de 100 articles
c'est au minimum 1000 amendements aient
au minimum 30 décrets d'application
alors par conséquent il faut bien se
rendre compte qu'on ne peut pas
continuer dans cette voie avec des lois
qui salle qui s'allonge de plus en plus
où l'assemblée nationale comme le sénat
exerçant normalement leur pouvoir
d'amendement augmente le texte initial
et on arrive en fin de parcours à des
techs très long à n'était pas toujours
cohérent et alors qu'une loi cours de
4,5 article permet très naturellement
d'éviter ce genre d'écueil est de faire
en sorte que les les décrets sortent
rapidement
j'ajouterai que comme je les dis ce
n'est pas seulement la faute du
gouvernement c'est aussi la faute du
parlement bien sûr nous faisons un
certain nombre d'efforts et il suffit de
regarder le travail très important que
même les parlementaires avec l'ensemble
des questions que nous pouvons adresser
au gouvernement les questions écrites
les questions orales les questions
cribles les questions d'actualité on a
tout un éventail mais je trouve qu en
étudiant ces questions il ya un certain
nombre d'anomalies qui apparaissent
première anomalie
le gouvernement ne répond pas très
souvent aux questions écrites
j'ai un certain nombre de questions
écrites rentrée où le gouvernement n'a
pas répondu depuis six mois depuis un an
et cetera
sans explication et sans le dire
pourquoi il ya donc la nécessité que le
gouvernement réponde un peu mieux aux
questions écrites
nous n'utilisons pas toujours les
questions comme il faudrait et nous
devrions et je regrette que nous n'ayons
pas le 6
m1 britanniques ou en début de chaque
séance nous adressons aux ministres qui
est là pendant une demi heure des
questions véritablement portant sur
l'application des lois et nous devrions
faire cela très rapidement une demi
heure à chaque fois on perdrait pas
beaucoup de temps l'on aurait d'autres
activités de contrôle qui seraient
réalisés plus facile je reprends de la
proposition de monsieur colin que je
trouve bonne c'est à dire chargé le
rapporteur d'une loi d'assurer le suivi
de l'application de celle-ci peut-être
pas en faisant un rapport très fort bel
v un rapport oral devant sa propre
commission
cela permettrait tout de même d'avancer
un peu plus facilement et puis il ya une
chose que nous n'avons pas abordé c'est
que les lois c'est comme une mais nous
ne les nettoyons pas il ya donc un
travail de nettoyage des lois que nous
devons pouvoir assurer et qui est de
notre mission et de notre fonction alors
tout ça pour dire que peut-être c'est
parce que nous avons trop de travail
assuré que en fin de compte nous avons
cette situation trop de travail pour le
gouvernement trop de travail pour le
parlement il faut par maman savoir
souffler pour avancer merci la parole
est à madame nathalie goulet pour
l'union centriste savant nathalie tous
mes oeufs
même le président ce ministre mes chers
collègues nous sommes un certain nombre
sur ses bancs à avoir souhaité un jour
qui une loi ballet qui quelques mois de
pause dans un calendrier législatif
aussi dense que varié auquel le
parlement est soumis depuis quelques
années par faudrait au gré de
l'actualité le président colin l'a dit
les chiens qui mordent les manèges qui
tournent les piscines qui curieusement
sont remplies d'eau et qu'il faut
maintenant transformer en fort knox
cette fougue législatif j'emploie
d'habitude un mot un peu moins noble a
pour conséquence une très grande
incertitude juridique nous avons même
assisté au cours des dernières années à
des innovations législatives monsieur le
ministre
des dispositions applicables avant que
la loi ne soit votée
la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle la publicité à la
télévision la fin d'être la tva dans la
restauration
j'en oublie sûrement ce débat vient donc
à point nommé
il est vrai que notre il est vrai aussi
que notre législation internationale
n'est pas mieux loti je n'oublie pas que
je suis membre de cet auguste de
commissions et parmi les lois qui font
l'objet d'un examen au parlement une
vingtaine de projets de loi de
ratification de traités d'accords
internationaux ont été déposées à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat et
sont en attente de l'examen ce qui n'est
pas négligeable
plus du double c'est à dire une
quarantaine de conventions sont signées
et devant être examiné par le parlement
mais n'ont pas encore fait l'objet de
projets de loi
je suis certaine monsieur le ministre
que pour vous pouvez faire état de ce
point auprès de madame le ministre
d'état ministre des affaires étrangères
l'objectif du gouvernement est de
parvenir à prendre toutes les mesures
réglementaires requises dans un délai de
six mois avant la publication de la loi
et lorsqu'on prend connaissance des
statistiques et des rapports non nous
sommes destinataire il est vrai que le
score n'est pas très glorieux
moi je m'intéresse pas aux statistiques
monsieur le ministre je suis un sénateur
de terrain qui plus est renouvelable
donc voyez vous je vais vous interroger
sur un cas précis le texte adopté si
sereinement dans cette maison sur la
réforme des collectivités territoriales
prévoit un renouvellement des cdc
dont le pouvoir est accrue hall au titre
de l'article 53 de la loi
une circulaire d'information générale du
27 décembre retranscrit les dispositions
légales en matière de calendrier de la
refonte de l'intercommunalité
le ministre précise même dès le premier
paragraphe
j'appelle votre attention sur le
calendrier resserré de la mise en oeuvre
des dispositions relatives aux schémas
départementaux de coopération
intercommunale
par suite dit il vous serez tenu informé
de la publication des décrets c'est
quand même assez normal en page 2 le
ministre mentionne un calendrier
fortement contre la circulaire précise
en outre page si ce dernier paragraphe
en page 7
le schéma sera arrêté le 31 décembre
2011 ces délais resserré aussi je vous
demande de présenter votre projet à la
cdc idée le mois d'avril 2011
la circulaire précise que les cdc i
doivent être renouvelées avant le 16
mars
mais voilà les décrets ne sont pas
sortis ou alors viennent de sortir mais
ils n'ont pas été portés à la
connaissance des intéressés je les
surveille avec macaulay avec jacqueline
gourault comme le lait sur le feu
et voilà une commission qui va être
essentiel au bon fonctionnement de la
loi nouvelle
en tout cas qui va donner l'occasion aux
élus de toutes tendances de s'exprimer
sur la composition qu'est soumise à
l'élection et dont les élus eux mêmes
pas plus que les préfets ne connaissent
aujourd'hui avec exactitude les
dispositions réglementaires
nous sommes le 12 janvier mais d'ici le
16 mars date fixée par la circulaire les
élus territoriaux doivent être informés
sollicité pour la composition 2 ou des
listes faute de quoi reconnaissez le
monsieur le ministre
les jeux sont un peu faussés j'ajoute
comme le fait d'ailleurs la circulaire
pages cette note numéro cinq en bas de
page
il est à noter qu'en raison des
élections cantonales prévues le 20 et le
27 mars
vous aurez à solliciter à nouveau la
désignation des représentants du conseil
général à d'assez dci à l'issue du
renouvellement cantonal
nous parlons de 10% des membres de la
cdc y la cdc
nouvellement composé ne pourra dès lors
être complètement opérationnel que début
avril
au mieux je ne crois pas qu'il s'agisse
là monsieur le ministre de conditions
tolérable pour faire accepter des
réformes importantes qui bouscule bien
des départements comme l'a justement dit
la présidente emblématique de la cdc du
pays du camembert non moins emblématique
commune de mon modeste département en
commentant un projet carte élaborée sur
la base des recensement insee
nous ne sommes pas des veaux qu'on
change d'herbage je voulais donc
monsieur le ministre vous souligner ce
point je crois que c'est important si
vous voulez que cette réforme soit
acceptée sur le terrain et ne soit pas
suicidaire pour les sénateurs
renouvelables qui vous ont fait
confiance
faites donc décalé le calendrier
intenable
sauf à ressembler à une parodie indigne
de notre démocratie et des élus locaux
qui la font vivre au quotidien
vous pouvez retarder un peu monsieur le
ministre les décrets au tout aussi
intolérable en matière de normes
environnementales ou normes de cantine
scolaire vous nous rendre et là pour le
coup un grand service pour conclure
monsieur mini je voudrais évoquer un
sujet qui ne me préoccupe pas du tout et
qui ne concerne pas du tout la moitié de
cette assemblée il s'agit du mode de
calcul des grands électeurs
en effet le pays a connu un certain
nombre de recensement depuis 2001 le
mode de calcul des grands électeurs
varie vous le savez mathématiquement une
commune qui passe de 498 à 502 habitants
ce n'est pas très important à paris mais
dans un département ça passe de 1 à 3
nombre de grands électeurs
de même les villes ont perdu un certain
nombre d'habitants et là aussi le nombre
des ans électeur peut changer la
circulaire fixant les règles de calcul
doit en principe être publié au mois de
juin
ne pensez vous pas monsieur le ministre
qu'il serait intéressant d'être en
possession de ce document
un peu plus tôt pour que chacun d'entre
nous puisse adopter les stratégies de
campagne les plus appropriés la campagne
sénatoriale vous savez n'est pas un long
fleuve tranquille
et donc je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre doit apporter des réponses à
cette intéressante question
merci madame
brice la parole est à monsieur jean
pierre sueur pour le groupe socialiste
mais
je
un médecin
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voulais
que d'abord remercier notre collègue
monsieur yvon collin d'avoir à mener ce
débat et le remercier aussi pour
l'initiative qui l'a annoncé et qui
m'apparaît particulièrement pertinente
monsieur le ministre je suis sûr vous
connaissant que vous avez lu le rapport
du sénat avec une grande attention et je
tiens d'ailleurs à rendre hommage à
l'ensemble des administrateurs décéda
qui ont fait cet excellent travail très
précis qui a dû demander beaucoup de
temps et le meilleur hommage qu'on
puisse leur rendre c'est de faire bon
usage de ce rapport or il ne vous a pas
échappé que la situation n'est pas bonne
car je cite ce rapport page 27 d'une
année parlementaire à l'autre le taux de
publication au 30 septembre des mesures
réglementaires prescrit s'est nettement
dégradée nous sommes passés de 27 % pour
l'année 2008-2009 à 26,1 pour cent pour
l'année 2009 2010 alors il ya là quelque
chose de profondément anormal et
monsieur le ministre je voulais insister
sur une autre anomalie
car cet excellent rapport montre que
lorsque l'on se concentre sur les lois
pour lequel votre gouvernement a demandé
la procédure accélérée et bien le taux
de publication des textes réglementaires
est encore plus faible et il a chuté
considérablement entre les deux années
parlementaire que je viens de citer
en effet monsieur le ministre si g
exclu les lois qui en vertu de la
constitution donne lieu à la procédure
accélérée c'est à dire les lois de
finances et bien pour les projets de loi
pour lesquelles vous avez demandé la
procédure accélérée
le taux de publication des textes
réglementaires et de 12 5%
alors mes chers collègues il y a là un
véritable dévoiement de la procédure
accélérée
parce que si vous nous dites monsieur le
ministre c'est tellement urgent qu'il
faut aller vite et il ne faut plus qu'il
y ait de lecture dans chaque assemblée
avant la commission mixte paritaire une
lecture suffit parce que c'est urgent eh
bien monsieur le ministre c'est urgent
alors comment se fait-il que lorsque
l'on fait le bilan
il y a à peine 12,5 pour cent des textes
réglementaires qui sont publiés si c'est
urgent je pense que vous avez dans votre
poche au moment où vous présenter le
projet de loi les textes réglementaires
que s'ils ne sont pas prêts dès que la
loi est promulguée
vous vous attachez à les faire paraître
or ce n'est pas le cas et l'on voit
ainsi que la procédure accélérée qui
devrait être une exception devient une
procédure de facilité en réalité c'est
simplement une procédure de facilité et
cela n'a rien à voir avec l'urgence du
sujet sauf quelques cas où effectivement
il y a urgence
alors je peux citer un cas que j'ai déjà
évoqué dans cette enceinte qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur
voyez vous monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues le sénat a adopté en
décembre 2004 une disposition relative à
un médicament dont on a beaucoup parlé
on parle beaucoup de médicaments en ce
moment qui s'appelle le distilbène
vous savez que les femmes qui se sont vu
prescrire du distilbène ont connu des
difficultés
c est que leurs enfants leur fille
particulièrement ont des grossesses
difficiles donc suite un débat le sénat
suivi ensuite par l'assemblée nationale
qui comme le sénat a délibéré à
l'unanimité a décidé que ces femmes
devaient bénéficier d'un congé
spécifique et bien entre le jour
monsieur le ministre
où la loi a été promulguée et le jour où
le deuxième des deux décrets nécessaires
a été publié monsieur le ministre attire
votre attention
il s'est passé exactement cinq ans six
mois et 14 jours
j'ai les lettres de nombreuses femmes
qui me disaient mais enfin c'est la loi
je ne peux pas en bénéficier pourquoi je
peux vous fournir j'ai d'ailleurs écrit
une publication
j'ai fait une déclaration devant le
congrès de l'association des e/s france
je tiens à rendre hommage d'ailleurs à
ces femmes qui ont mené un combat
exemplaire courageux eux devant les
juridictions et bien comment comprendre
que pendant cinq ans des femmes qui
devaient bénéficier de ce congé
spécifique parce qu'elle était enceinte
n'en est pas bénéficié comment le
justifier
alors je peux vous fournir toutes les
questions écrites les questions orales
les interventions ministères et toutes
les phrases toutes faites
il faut une concertation il faut prendre
le problème dans son ensemble il faut
consulter ceux ci cela etc
mais c'est impossible donc je cite cela
il a fallu que j'intervienne auprès de
madame bachelot lors de la loi sur
l'hôpital qui m'a dit mais c'est
révoltant c'est insupportable ça va être
réglé et il a fallu encore attendre des
mois pour que la ce pour que cela soit
réglé
g je me suis permis mes chers collègues
de citer cet exemple pour bien montrer
qu'il ne s'agit pas seulement de la
réalité statistique monde et décrets les
décrets
et la publication ou la non publication
d'un décret peut avoir des conséquences
très direct et parfois très
préjudiciable pour certains et certaines
de nos concitoyens alors pour finir on
peut naturellement et mettre tous les
voeux c'est la saison à l'égard du
gouvernement à l'égard du parlement
je crois que le parlement fait largement
son travail par les questions que nous
posons par les rapports qui sont publiés
et nous veillons beaucoup à ce sujet je
vais vous dire monsieur le ministre je
pense qu'on ne s'en sortira pas s'il
n'existe pas de mesures plus coercitives
et je crois qu'il y a en effet deux
directions dans lesquelles il faudrait
travailler
la première c'est celle du conseil
d'état en effet le conseil d'état peut
condamner le gouvernement pour
non-application de la loi et je souhaite
pour ma part que ces procédures se
multiplient parce que il y a là une voie
pour obtenir satisfaction et je suis
totalement favorable à ce que vous avez
proposé me suivront colin parce que je
me suis déjà trouvé devant le conseil
d'état ou 60 70 sénateurs de mon groupe
avait déposé un recours par rapport au
texte d'une ordonnance l'ordonance elle
n'avait pas donné lieu à ratification
donc elle était encore un document à
caractère administratif et le conseil
d'état a beaucoup tourné autour du sujet
et a dit nonobstant le fait je résume
qu'il n'est pas nécessaire de statuer
sur la question de savoir si les
parlementaires sont recevables ou ne
sont pas recevables
il me semble que votre initiative est
excellente
parce que qui peut nier que c'est de bon
sens que les parlementaires sont
particulièrement fondé à intervenir
auprès du conseil d'état pour non
application de la loi qu'ils ont voté
donc si vous prenez une mesure vous
proposer une mesure
initiative qui permettrait de régler
cette question de l'intérêt à agir ce
serait très positif
enfin et je termine madame la présidente
il y a ce qui relève du gouvernement
vous savez qu'une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle a été proposée en mai
2006 pour changer l'article 34 de la
constitution je demande s'il ne faudrait
pas continuer à explorer cette voie et
je vois deux moyens ne serait-il pas
possible alors il faudrait naturellement
travailler la question juridique mais
que la constitution ou la loi organique
prévoit que dès lors qu'un texte
d'application n'est pas prévu n'est pas
paru au bout de deux ou trois ans la loi
la disposition légale législatives est
devenue caduque
à partir de ce moment là il y aurait
quelque chose de coercitif car je crois
que s'il n'y a pas une dispositions
coercitives et bien on ne changera pas
les choses
donc je suis d'accord sur le fait que
cela demande réflexion
mais il me semble qu'il faudrait que
l'on avance à cet égard et alors on
pourrait aussi autre position et
monsieur le ministre je serais intéressé
par votre réponse à ce sujet ce qui a
été évoqué tout à l'heure par monsieur
le colin la décision qu'avait prise au
par monsieur gérard je ne sais plus mais
enfin je les associe tous les deux par
michel rocard de demander que l'on
publie en même temps que le projet de
loi
les projets de textes réglementaires à
partir de ce moment là d'ailleurs ça
éclairerait le débat parlementaire et
tout serait transparent je pense que ce
serait une bonne méthode
alors je termine madame la présidente et
en car je ne veux absolument pas abuser
de votre indulgence que je connais
je dirais simplement que mes chers
collègues
il faut en finir avec ce pouvoir
exorbitant dont dispose aujourd'hui tout
gouvernement
tout gouvernement dispose du pouvoir
exorbitant de ne pas appliquer la loi
or les ministes sont les serviteurs de
la loi il suffit tout simplement de ne
pas publier les décrets et ainsi on peut
et devrait pour que la loi ne s'applique
pas ce pouvoir était exorbitant et il
faut rompre avec cette fâcheuse pratique
la parole et à madame françoise laborde
pour le groupe rds on prend du retard
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues après année
après année il est toujours navrant de
constater les retards accumulés par le
gouvernement dans les diction des
mesures réglementaires d'application des
lois il faut bien sûr reconnaître que
des progrès notables ont été réalisés à
la fin de la session 2002 2003 près de
45% des lois votées n'était pas
applicable tout ramené en moyenne autour
de 25% ces dernières années progress
secte mais résultats toujours très
insuffisants au regard des enjeux que
soulève ce débat les lois que nous
votons entre en vigueur dès leur
promulgation par le président de la
république
fruit de la délibération des
représentants de la souveraineté
nationale la loi un quart de la volonté
générale dans l'esprit que concevait
déjà les révolutionnaires de 1789 à cet
égard le pouvoir réglementaire ne doit
qu'appliquer les grandes lignes fixées
par le législateur en fixant les
modalités d'application de la loi en
réglant les détails qui ne sont pas en
principe du domaine de la loi
malheureusement ce schéma ne fonctionne
que sur le papier cela a été dit au 30
septembre dernier seuls 135 mesures
réglementaires sur les 670 prévues par
les lois votées
durant la session 2009 2010 avaient été
publiées soit un taux dramatiquement bas
de 25 % contre 27 % à pareille date lors
de la session précédente
les facteurs de ces retards récurrents
sont multiples mais au loin d'être un
supporter insurmontable l'augmentation
du nombre de lois votées chaque année en
est bien sûr un elle contribue à
alourdir la tâche à la fois du parlement
obligé de légiférer dans la
précipitation et de l'administration
confronté à un suivi réglementaire plus
dense dans son rapport pour 2007 le
conseil d'état évoqué comme sources de
cette inflation l'adoption de
dispositions dont l'utilité et la
pertinence sont douteuses ou encore la
tendance a donc
des textes d'un niveau supérieur à celui
qui résulte de la hiérarchie des normes
comme par exemple la loi du 10 mars 2010
visant à rendre obligatoire
l'installation de détecteurs de fumée
dans tous les lieux d'habitation qui
relèvent clairement du domaine
réglementaire les malfaçons législatives
existent c'est certain mais encore
faut-il considérer les conditions
souvent difficiles dans lesquelles les
projets de loi sont discutés et votés
or sur ce point précis le partage de
l'ordre du jour entre chaque assemblée
et le gouvernement est loin d'avoir
résolu le problème
le gouvernement continue à nous
soumettre dans le cadre de la procédure
accélérée des projets de loi rédigé à la
hâte en réponse à des faits divers et
qui ne vise qu'à tirer partie de
l'opinion publique ou à flatter une
certaine démagogie
mais même en la matière votre
gouvernement monsieur le ministre ne va
pas au bout de sa logique
ainsi la loi du 18 mars 2003 sur la
sécurité intérieure texte emblématique
de la lutte contre l'insécurité est
chère au président de la république n'a
t'elle pas encore reçu tous ces décrets
d'application tout comme la loi du 21
novembre 2007 relative à la maîtrise de
l'immigration ou encore la loi raffarin
sur les libertés et responsabilités
locales du 9 août 2004
il serait pourtant utile que votre
gouvernement s'applique à lui même le
même elle pour publier les décrets
d'application que celui qu'il exige de
nous à voter ces textes dans la
précipitation
je voudrais également évoqué les
difficultés que rencontrent les
fonctionnaires des services centraux à
s'adapter au rythme effréné de la
production législative si les projets de
décret a rédigé sont de plus en plus
nombreux les anges les agents publics
chargés de ce travail sont quant à eux
de moins en moins grâce au miracle de la
rgpp et aux effets du dogme du non
remplacement du départ à la retraite
d'un fonctionnaire sur deux il est
certain que la réduction des effectifs
ne contribuera ni à améliorer le travail
des fonctionnaires
chargé du suivi réglementaire ni à
réduire le délai moyen de promulgation
des décrets
or le travail de résorption des décrets
en attente sur des textes antérieurs
paraît considérable pour preuve au 135
mesures publiées en 2009 2010 s'ajoutent
les 450 de mesures réglementaires prises
en 2009 2010 aussi pour appliquer des
lois antérieurement promulgué dans 71
pour des textes de plus de deux ans
plus largement l'accumulation des
retards dans la publication des décrets
d'application n'est pas acceptable tant
du point de vue du parlement que celui
de nos concitoyens ces retards porte
atteinte à la volonté du parlement car
il prive des laudes effet les lois qu'il
a voté suscitant l'incompréhension
légitimes de nos concitoyens à qu'il
nous faut expliquer qu'une loi votée et
promulguée est en réalité inapplicable
il contribue donc de fait à alimenter
une insécurité juridique
d'autant plus perturbante que
l'instabilité normative vient encore
complexifier la lecture et la
compréhension du droit positif
des solutions existent pour remédier à
ce mal le président yvon collin les a
déjà évoqué sans doute ne revient-il
également à nos parlementaires de mieux
de mieux nous saisir des outils dont
nous disposons pour mieux contrôler
l'exécution des lois est développé sur
ce point des solutions constructives
monsieur le ministre nous attendons
néanmoins aujourd'hui que le
gouvernement nous éclaire sur les
raisons de ces retards que nous ne
pouvons tolérer au nom de l'intérêt
général et qui nous exposent les moyens
qu'il compte mettre en oeuvre pour
engager les méthodes de travail
respectueuses de la volonté du parlement
je remercie merci madame la parole est à
madame la présidente borvo cohen seat
pour le groupe
crc spg bonjour l'instant
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
alors je crois que je voudrais bien pour
commencer que bien entendu le
gouvernement s'est préoccupé de la
question